from The Washington Post
Lisa whitenack
loved sharks as a kid she spent rainy
days leafing through a guide to sharks
and Readers Digest every summer she
would watch shark week which is
discovery's annual TV event that spy
light that spotlights the ocean Predator
with seven days of dedicated programming
but when the scientists appeared on her
TV screen she rarely saw any women she
could look up to
why would I know I could do that white
Knack said I don't come from a family of
scientists I didn't see very many people
that look like me on television white
Knack now a biology professor at
Allegheny College in Pennsylvania found
her way into shark research anyway when
the pandemic lockdowns began in 2020 she
saw an opportunity to study the sources
of her old misconceptions was Shark Week
feeding audiences the wrong messages
about sharks and who studies them
white Knack led a team of researchers to
examine hundreds of Shark Week episodes
that aired between 1988 and 2020.
this is the kind of research that's
being done this is the kind of this is
the kind of scientific research that's
being funded these days
um if you're wondering what the what the
scientists are are working on
you know like why why haven't we gotten
back to the Moon yet why don't we have a
cure for cancer yet well they're the
scientists are working on this sort of
thing
uh
looking into the the diversity in Shark
Week programming in a study published
last month by the public library of
science their research claims that
discoveries programming emphasized
negative messages about sharks lacked
useful messaging about shark
conservation and
and overwhelmingly featured white men as
experts including several men with the
same name the programming featured more
white experts and commentators named
Mike than women so they're even looking
at there there are not just too many
white men who are studying sharks but
there are too many white men named Mike
can we at least get some other names in
there
um anyway it goes on
let's see
David schiffman is a conservationist at
Arizona State University was a co-author
on the study when there are hundreds of
people of color interested who work in
this field and when my field is more
than half women maybe it's not an
accident anymore that they're only
featuring white men
Discovery did not respond to requests
for comment on the study's findings
and by the way that's not because
Discovery is just going to laugh this
off as they should okay it's not because
they're laughing it off and saying what
their response should be you know the
response should be like are you kidding
me I don't who cares
but no they're just they're they're
talking to their PR people and
eventually they're going to issue some
uh you know mayor culpa come to Jesus
great grand apology if they haven't
already I haven't even looked up this
this story is a few days old so they may
have already done this
um
outlining what all the steps they're
going to take to make sure there's more
diversity in Shark Week programs that's
what's going to happen
the company told NBC Boston that it
wouldn't comment on a study that has yet
to pass any scientific approvals after
preliminary version was presented in
2021. it has since undergone a
scientific review
okay
well we could continue reading that if
you want but I think we probably don't
need to
we are and we are so far beyond the
bounds of parity at this point
that I did I read through the entire
thing because I was honest to God
expecting that they would also say that
the focus on great white sharks in
particular is racist so that there's
some kind of encoded message there that
we're always taught oh great white I was
really expecting that like I'm not
unironically I was expecting that would
be in there and it wasn't
but uh nearly as absurd as that
and remember it's not just that there's
not enough diversity among people who
are talking about sharks
uh but also that the that it is painting
a negative message about sharks
sharks are actually quite friendly
like nothing to worry about if you're
swimming in the ocean and you see that
the dorsal fin go by nothing to worry
about don't uh don't be don't be don't
make assumptions don't make a biased
stereotypical assumptions just based on
the fact that there is this prehistoric
death machine swimming right next to you
one thing for sure next year's Shark
Week okay after this next year Shark
Week you've never seen diversity like
what they're gonna do and every single
Stark expert I guarantee you there will
not be one white male shark expert
allowed in next next year is a shark
week uh certainly none named Mike you're
gonna see there's gonna be black shark
ax but they're gonna find women there's
there's they're gonna throw in some
trans shark experts
and if there aren't any trans shark
experts they'll just bring in some trans
people in general whether they know
anything about sharks or not maybe
they'll bring in a trans person who's
seen the movie Jaws and uh get there get
their comment on it
you've never seen diversity like what
we're going to see next next year
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts